il
1936 e un giovane ricercatore austriaco
naturalizzato canadese
scopre che applicando stimoli diversi
sia fisici che psicologici ai topi da
esperimento ottiene sempre la stessa
risposta corporea come ad esempio la
produzione di ulcere nello stomaco
perché vi racconto questa storia perché
questo scienziato di nome fans seri che
verrà poi definito il padre dello stress
dimostra qualcosa che intuitivamente
ognuno di noi conosce
ovvero che mente corpo non sono separati
ma sono strettamente interconnessi con
l'unica no e la loro relazione è
fondamentale per la nostra salute e il
nostro benessere
da questo filone di ricerca nasce poi
una disciplina dal nome impronunciabile
la psico neuro endocrino immunologia che
chiameremo familiar mente con l'acronimo
lei
io l'ho conosciuta quando appena
laureata cercavo nuovi strumenti per far
fronte alla sofferenza umana e anche per
superare quel senso di impotenza che a
volte ci prende quando non riusciamo ad
aiutare gli altri e mi appassionai
subito inizia così una meravigliosa
avventura di scoperta che dura tuttora
in breve la play si occupa di studiare
le relazioni più che i singoli elementi
dell'organismo umano
quindi alla play non basterà sapere come
è fatto un cuore o come funziona
vorrà conoscere in che rapporto si trova
ad esempio con il cervello con il fegato
con il sistema immunitario
quindi un modo totalmente nuovo di
concepire l'uomo e la sua salute perché
ogni elemento non è separato ma tutti
concorrono al funzionamento del tutto
questa avventura ricca di relazioni
connessioni ha cambiato profondamente la
mia prospettiva professionale e anche la
mia visione della vita
la mia formazione si basava sullo studio
dei singoli sistemi quindi ad esempio se
vi fa male un piede cureremo in piede
giusto
adesso però sappiamo che per curare un
infiammazione a un piede potrebbe essere
necessario prima guarire l'intestino
oppure che se abbiamo un dolore al cuore
magari dobbiamo prenderci cura di
un'emozione come nella sindrome del
cuore infranto
si chiama sindrome di tako tsubo la
conoscete
è una malattia cardiaca causata da
intensi stress e forti emozioni e si
chiama così perché il cuore prende la
forma di un anfora tipicamente usata in
giappone per la caccia al polpo
quindi tutto è in relazione con tutto
perché stiamo un sistema unico
psicosomatico è una visione comunitaria
della salute e della malattia
lo dice la fisica
lo dicono le tradizioni spirituali di
tutto il mondo per la medicina ancora
complesso applicare questa visione così
globale sistemica alla salute umana
allora la play ci sta aiutando in questo
passaggio di prospettiva
studiando scientificamente le relazioni
tra le cellule tra i sistemi tra mente
corpo e anche tra noi e l'ambiente
prendiamo ad esempio il nostro rapporto
con i microbi un argomento che mi ha
sempre affascinato
pensate che la densità di microrganismi
nel nostro intestino è tale da renderlo
uno dei luoghi più densamente popolati
da microrganismi dell'intero pianeta
e un chilo e mezzo il peso
approssimativo della comunità di microbi
che ospitiamo circa quanto un cervello
umano
quindi ognuno di noi è un piccolo
ecosistema
e credo che dovremmo ricordarcene quando
ci sentiamo un po soli
i ricercatori ci dicono che ospitiamo
oltre 1.000 specie di questi
microorganismi di cui 400 almeno nel
solo intestino
queste comunità contengono tre milioni
di geni e pensate che quelli umani sono
foro 23000 quindi in pratica nel nostro
corpo
conteniamo più geni di origine microbica
che umani
e non solo batteri almeno il nostro il
lotto per cento del nostro dna sembra
essere costituito da materiale genetico
proveniente da virus antichissimi con
cui siamo entrati in contatto in qualche
momento dell'evoluzione
l'importanza per la salute umana di
questi microrganismi è talmente alta da
essere considerati ormai un altro organo
proprio come il fegato i reni polmoni
e le interazioni che sviluppano con i
nostri sistemi sono così strette
che non possiamo più considerarci esseri
separati ma addirittura un unico super
organismo
e se poi influenzano durante tutta la
nostra vita attività fisiologiche come
ad esempio la digestione ma svolgono
anche importantissime funzioni come la
regolazione del nostro sistema
immunitario
siccome parlano la stessa lingua delle
nostre cellule addirittura modificano la
chimica cerebrale
quindi possono influenzare sentimenti
pensieri e comportamenti
qualcosa di incredibile
tra l'altro sono molto sensibili allo
stress e alle emozioni e quindi dobbiamo
prenderci ne cura perché se questa
delicatissima connessione si rompe
possono insorgere diversi problemi di
salute
grazie a tutte queste scoperte
ho smesso di considerare il corpo umano
con una macchina costituita di pezzi che
si rompono e si riparano
io ho iniziato invece a vedere questa
meravigliosa rete di cellule che
comunicano interagiscono cellule umane
cellule microbiche
cellule che costituiscono agli alberi
fiori anche tutti gli animali
la vita si manifesta
in tutti questi modi evolve in
complessità ma mantiene le stesse
caratteristiche biologiche
ecco perché la salute è globale riguarda
ogni elemento di questa comunità
planetaria e forse universale che
scambia continuamente materia energia
informazione evolve insieme e mantiene
le caratteristiche necessarie alla vita
attraverso le relazioni ci manteniamo in
salute
quando ci innamoriamo e ci baciamo
oltre al benessere provocate dall'ondata
di ormoni neurotrasmettitori anche il
nostro sistema immunitario si attiva
diventa più pronta a rispondere alle
infezioni
e questo sembra grazie allo scambio di
ben 80 milioni di batteri
viviamo un esistenza a fondata sulle
relazioni
quando eravamo piccoli è stato il
contatto con nostra mamma che ci ha
permesso di imparare a regolare il
battito cardiaco la respirazione e anche
dar voce alle emozioni di pancia
il nostro sistema nervoso il nostro
cervello si sono evoluti grazie alle
esperienze sociali quindi anche da
adulti continuiamo ad avere bisogno
degli altri
quando ci sentiamo soli isolati
disconnessi il nostro cervello invia dei
segnali di allarme a tutto il corpo come
se fossimo di fronte a un pericolo e
questo stress modifica ormoni
neurotrasmettitori e anche l'attività
del nostro sistema immunitario
se troppo intenso dura troppo a lungo
può provocare dei danni alla salute
proprio come farebbe una malattia
cronica
invece quando abbiamo relazioni profonde
e significative e ci sentiamo parte di
una comunità più vasta che ci sostiene
allora siamo più rilassati
siamo più resilienti siamo chi in salute
e diventiamo anche capaci di esprimere
le nostre potenzialità nella società
quando realizziamo chi siamo i nostri
cervelli si sincronizzano e diventano
come un cervello solo come in questo
momento in questa sala
e come in questo esperimento condotto
dai ricercatori dell'istituto di
neuropsicologi ca che hanno studiato
proprio il fenomeno della
sincronizzazione cerebrale di gruppo
potete vedere nell'immagine a sinistra
le onde cerebrali di 12 persone diverse
in uno stato di bassa empatia basta
connessione e in effetti le loro onde
sono tutte diverse ma nell'immagine a
destra possiamo vedere una tale armonia
da sembrare un'unica onda ripetuta 12
volte invece sono sempre le onde di 12
persone diverse ma in uno stato di
profonda
autoconsapevolezza e connessione
da quando questa comprensione si è
radicata profondamente in me ovvero che
non siamo separati ma siamo
profondamente interconnessi e la nostra
un'esistenza concretamente relazionale
ho iniziato a vedere relazioni
connessioni ovunque
sarà capitato anche a voi di aver avuto
sempre davanti agli occhi qualcosa che
però non avete mai veramente visto a me
è capitato quando ho comprato la mia
prima motocicletta e a un certo punto il
mondo mi è sembrato pieno di
motociclette e motociclisti
alla fine ho capito che la nostra salute
dipende dalla qualità di tutte queste
relazioni e quindi non può esserci
salute se non è globale
ecco perché dobbiamo prenderci cura di
ogni elemento dai più piccoli microbi
del nostro intestino agli alberi che ci
permettono di respirare
scegliere con cura quello che mangiamo
dove viviamo come comunichiamo e creare
relazioni profonde e significative
come ogni cellula partecipa e collabora
per il funzionamento dell'intero
organico
ognuno di noi essenziale per la salute
della comunità planetaria
perché non esiste lio separato esiste
solo il noi
allora vorrei provare con voi per
qualche minuto a sperimentare questa
interconnessione
quindi vi chiedo di chiudere tutti gli
occhi
e di provare a portare l'attenzione al
vostro respiro
molto semplicemente stiamo con
l'attenzione sull'area che entra e
l'area che esce e il corpo che respira
ad ogni respiro il corpo che si espande
e si rilassa
l'aria entra l'area esce il corpo si
espande e si rilassa
e forse dopo alcuni respiri potremmo
notare che i confini del corpo non
sembrano più così netti così rigidi ma
che se stiamo con l'attenzione sulla
postazione respiratoria
possiamo iniziare a percepire che il
nostro respiro si connette al respiro
delle persone intorno a noi e diventiamo
un unica grande bolla di respiro
respiriamo tutti insieme in questa sala
come un'unica bolla di respiro
e possiamo delicatamente riaprire gli
occhi
e forse da oggi avremo un nuovo sguardo
[Musica]